[Applause]  Jimmy Kimmel drops one awkward joke but  also makes a sweet gesture at the Emmys  ladies and gentlemen four-time Emmy  Award winner dr. Bill Cosby he's not  really her I just wanted to see what you  guys would do  yes that was a Bill Cosby joke Sunday  nights but Kimmel also made this gesture  with help from his mom my mother made  7,000 peanut butter and jelly sandwiches  is anyone hungry right now okay let's  bring in the kids from stranger things  to pass the peanut butter and jelly  sandwiches out though that cute bit  wasn't without its punchlines my mom  usually writes notes in did she write  notes in the bags dear Amy you're the  funniest woman on television I wish you  were hosting the Emmys this year  I'm your number one fan bring back Parks  and Rec indeed that was a reference to  Amy Poehler let us know what you thought  of the Emmys we're on twitter at ET now  you